hello everybody and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown my name is
alex muller and i'm glad to be your
instructor this evening and tonight i
got a fun theme planned for you tonight
we're gonna be talking about pins
so uh the name of this lesson is the pin
is mightier than the sword keep that in
mind it's going to serve us really well
um
but before we start just an intro so
what is a pin it's a very common
strategy some people might have heard of
it maybe you know what it is but we're
just going to go over some real basic
idea here so uh a pin is a kind of
tactic in chess and in chess i like to
differentiate between tactics and
strategies
strategies are more long-term positional
plans and tactics are more quick
short-term ideas that are going to get
us an advantage so a pin is a tactic
it's going to be a quicker idea that's
just immediately going to get us some
kind of advantage
and it happens when one piece attacks a
second and if that piece it's the the
piece that's being attacked if it moves
then a third piece behind is the one
that's attacked
so we have just a simple intro to a game
here
and in this position we have to move
bishop to b5 that is played and this is
an absolute pin there's two kinds uh an
absolute pin is one where the piece that
is pinned
uh is stuck to the king right so in this
position if the knight were to try and
move anywhere
then white would take the king it would
be an illegal move because you can't
move into check
so an absolute pin means this piece
absolutely just cannot move the knight
is pinned to the king by the bishop
bishop to g4 on the other hand is
another kind of pin this is a relative
pin
so in this case our knight can move if
you see if i click on leach us it's got
some options for us
but the problem would be if i were to
move this knight
then the queen hangs
so i lose my queen uh so relative pin
means the piece it shouldn't move right
um
because i don't want to lose that
valuable piece
so again the basic idea of a pin is you
have one piece that's attacking in a
straight line
and it is keeping a piece stuck because
you don't want to lose the piece that's
more important behind it
okay so now that we know what a pen is
let's talk about three major principles
of a pinned piece
the first one and i like a lot of
alliteration so the first one pinned
pieces are petrified
they cannot move or at least they
shouldn't move so in this case
we have d4
knight to f6 bishop g5 this is a
trompowski and uh cooley29 glad to have
you in what's up um e6
knight to c3 this is just a possible
opening example bishop to b4 so now we
have two pins in the position
uh somebody tell me what kind of pin is
this our bishop on g5 pinning the knight
relative pin right it's not the king but
it's a very important piece so this
knight can move but probably shouldn't
this one on the other hand is what's it
called
it's absolutely right the bishop on b4
pinning the knight to the king it
actually can't move it's illegal
so we have our two kinds of pins
uh e4 castles
and in this position uh white to move
and play a really good move we're gonna
play e5
and our pawn attacks the knight and the
knight is petrified it's pinned it can't
move away as much as this knight would
love to run and hide if it does so we're
going to take the queen
so the best that black can play for is a
counter attack they might try h6
with the idea that if we take they're
going to take us in this particular
position white's actually much better
because bishop h4 g5 looks good
but it doesn't work
it looks like the pin is stopped but we
can take
and if queen takes f6 then our knights
are sorry our bishop survives
but if you take the bishop it's actually
checkmate in two moves
anybody want to take a gander and try
and get checkmate and two moves from
this position with white to move
so
uh queen where
the g4 queen g4 yeah this is check
the king has two legal moves h7 or h8
and regardless of where the king goes
our follow-up
into chiefs finding you seven defended
by the pawn this is checkmate
so
that's just one case where we can see
that this pin right was never addressed
uh
and there was we were ready to attack
this knight is petrified and because
black didn't acknowledge the threat we
were able to get an advantage here
here's another example of a possible
opening game this is a little more
complex but it's really really fun so i
wanted to at least show it off so
this is called the budapest gambit
where black is playing e5 and giving up
this pawn with the idea that we're going
to try and get it back and get white to
mess themselves up so pawn takes pawn
knight to g4 we're attacking hoping to
get the pawn back
uh bishop to f4 defending so we bring
out our second knight attack it twice
right
knight to f3
and we can't well we can attack it one
more time we can play queen to e7
but
uh we're going to play bishop to b4
check first because if queen to e7 first
we're trapping our bishop we want to
keep our pieces able to get developed
right if it's just sitting on the back
line it's not going to be helpful to us
bishop to b4 then there's two moves here
uh again the stress isn't super
important but some people don't want to
play knight to c3 because they're afraid
of doubling these pawns
this is actually okay for white so it's
not a big deal but because of that some
people will play knight to d2 this move
is also okay but notice
we've created an absolute pin
so we have one in the position already
the knight can't move we should be aware
of that
queen to e7 and now this piece is
attacked three times and there's not any
way for white to save it so a common
idea is to play a3 and say okay i can't
defend this knight or this pawn but i
can force you to make another move i can
make you move away and then maybe i'll
get something good
uh hello glad to have you again
but in this position there's actually a
fun trap
the move to play here is to take this
pawn and sacrifice the bishop and here's
the idea
if pawn takes then white because of a
pin
has checkmate
in one move
in this position i know it's wild
uh knights on c6 here
knight to d3 yeah and this is a
smothered checkmate where because this
queen now is pinning the pawn to the
king this is an absolute pin and the
king is fully trapped
so this knight is delivering the killing
blow
really really brutal um it's a fun one
to get in the game and the point isn't
necessarily to have prepared that but
it's a good example of showing that yeah
this pawn is totally petrified cannot
move um even though it costs white the
game if white were to try and take the
knight then we would take the king
anyway
so pin is really really valuable they
can give you a big advantage
we have a second principle here so our
first principle pin pieces are petrified
can't move second one is pinned pieces
don't protect
right normally a chess piece exerts some
influence on the board so in this case
this knight to f3 is actually
influencing i'll put a knight out here
all of these squares
it might not be a good idea for it to go
to those squares right in this case if
it were to go to d4 we would take it but
it's at least putting some pressure on
there and it's defending so that if
maybe white wants to play d4
it's supported um
so keeping in mind what your pieces are
aiming at where they're actually
attacking and defending is very helpful
but when a piece is pinned
it doesn't get to do that so this is
just one again opening example
and in this position bishop to b4 is
played
pinning the knight to the king
and white actually played a bad move
here they made the mistake of playing
bishop to c4 which normally is a great
move
developing our knight preparing to
castle
and attacking a key f7 square but
whites made a mistake because they
didn't acknowledge the power of this pin
so does anyone see what move black
should play in this position
there's two good moves but both of them
work on the same kind of principle
yes and i take c4 uh and the idea is
the knight's not actually defending that
pawn right normally
this knight would just capture us but
because of the pin it's petrified and so
it doesn't protect
um the alternative move is you can also
just take the knight first and then do
this
it works out kind of the same but
i actually like taking the pawn first
because even though we double these
pawns
uh our third principle which we're going
to get to in a second is we want to
pressure the pin to piece we're going to
put pressure on the pin piece um or pile
up on them uh because when a piece can't
move adding extra attackers is usually
going to be to our advantage right it
can't escape which is one of the natural
things to deal with an attack piece okay
but let's look at another quick example
here for pinned pieces don't protect so
in this game e4 e5
we have uh scotch
gambits
and again knowing the openings isn't
necessarily important but
in this position white has actually
chosen to sacrifice two pawns this is an
opening that i play all the time it's
probably my favorite opening
but white sacrifices instead of
recapturing on d4
they develop a bishop
and then instead of defending their pawn
they allow knight takes c4 so white has
given up two pawns but white plans to
win them back with some clever pins
so in this position um
the move to play is rook to e1
pinning the knight to the king and
hoping to you know just win this piece
you took two of my pawns but if i want a
piece that's great now black has a move
here that is uh looks really really
strong and looks almost undefeatable
anyone see what might you play had if
you had the black pieces
to defend your knight
and maybe cause some more mayhem
the five looks really good
we're defending the knight and we're
attacking our bishop so not only have
you solved the problem you're adding a
tempo you're making me do something with
this bishop and you're going to get an
extra move
but white can actually exploit this a
little bit and retain
a slight advantage or at least be not
worse
and the surprisingly i'll give you some
chances to take a look at some future
ones but the really cool move you can
play here is bishop takes d5
and you say okay well i'm just going to
take with the queen right why would you
sacrifice that piece but now if you take
a look this knight is pinned
this pawn
is pinned because if the pawn were to
move out of the way i would take your
queen
so we can play knight to c3
neither of these pieces can take our
knight
and we're attacking the queen and the
knight together so this is actually a
fork that works because of two pins it's
amazing
um
what are you gonna do the you're just
gonna have to move your queen away and
wherever you move it i'm just going to
take my knight back
and i'm going to win this pawn back
pretty easily if you try and defend this
pawn i don't even know how you would
um maybe something with the queen but
if you try something silly like this
then i'm gonna win your queen
double check
so i'm gonna win the pawns back and it's
a fine position for white
so i just wanted to show this one off
it's one of my favorite uh pins it's
really cool this is in the scotch gambit
it's called the anderson attack and it
relies on this really nice double pin
idea okay so pin pieces don't protect
right neither of these pieces are
defending the square
our third rule as i mentioned earlier is
we want to pile on or pressure the
pinned piece so in this example
hopefully you can see the pretty obvious
move here
knight to d5 right
we want to put pressure on this piece in
this position it's kind of a weird
imbalance where white has four pawns
versus two both sides have a knight and
white has a bishop and a rook versus a
queen
so it's a really weird imbalance hard to
say who's better it's going to be kind
of awkward to play either way
but if we were to just take this piece
and end the pin
then we haven't gained anything
it's just an even trade
but if we play knight to d5 we're able
to exploit the fact that this knight
can't move
if the queen were anywhere else um then
i could just back off and it'd still be
a weird imbalanced game but since the
queen is here and the night's pinned
nothing can really stop it you can
defend the knight sure but are you
really gonna trade your queen for my two
pieces
i just have a rook and two extra pawns
so
you're probably not gonna do that you're
probably gonna move
just away get out of the pin somewhere
and i'll take your piece and now i have
a rook and two pieces for this queen
plus some extra pawns it's still going
to be weird but i feel happy playing
this as white
so we want to put pressure on the pinned
pieces
in this position it's white to move does
anyone see
a good move you would play if you had
white in this position
yeah pawn to e5
with the really simple idea again the
knight can't move it's petrified so if
we were just to take it with the bishop
and move earlier we wouldn't have gained
anything but if we put pressure on it
it's going to give us a nice advantage
let's look at one final
example here we want to pressure the
pinned piece
and this is actually from a grand master
game that took place uh last year so
2021 between two grand masters uh or at
least actually no i think they're both
v-day masters but they're like over two
thousand very strong players and one of
them just made a really
massive miscalculation that involved a
pin um so it's this affects every level
of play
the game was a pierce defense
e4 d6
d4
knight f6
uh donkey boy i don't like the brit
opening because you're playing f4 very
early and you're exposing your king to
danger
bishop to g5 bishop to g7
queen to d2
and black's idea is they're going to get
a really fortified defensive setup their
king is going to be safe white's idea is
they're going to use their queen and
bishop to put pressure over on the king
side maybe launch some pawns so that's
kind of the general idea of this opening
but here's where it gets interesting is
white plays a massive or sorry black
plays a massive blunder in this position
typical moves here you might see are
castling or h6 both are fairly typical
maybe you might see c5
but in this position white actually
sorry black plays to move e5
and this is a break
a pawn break right fighting in the
center that is normally a good idea it's
fine to do this but it's a little too
early because black is a little too
exposed hasn't really castled and
there's actually a really big problem
uh does anyone want to take a second and
look at this position see if they have
any guesses for how white should gain an
advantage
and i will just give you a heads up if
you don't mind that's okay amazingly the
computer says this position is like
about even 0 0.
after e5 this is plus 8.
so white is up
almost a queen after this move because
it's that bad it looks fine but there's
a big problem and it all has to do with
this pin
so see if
you can figure out how to make uh an
advantageous position for white here
it's a little harder but any suggestions
i'm happy to take
i'm sorry
so you want this pawn to take on e5
well yeah no it's fine to take a look at
some ideas
okay so d takes e5 and maybe we're
exposing the king a little with bishop
to b5 i see our chat saying a few ideas
d take c
uh some people want to play knight d5
so let's just take a look at a few of
these so knight d5 is similar to what we
just saw i think in
this example right it's actually the
exact same setup we just have
a lot less pieces on the board
um the difference here
is knight d5 because black still has
these resources
um they can play a move like knight to
d7 and defend and black's going to hold
on here
so knight d5 doesn't quite work yet
bishop to b5 also looks like a fun move
but because of the pawn they're going to
be okay
they can hold on and just force us to
move back and then they have a little
extra time to do whatever they want
so a few people suggested yeah d takes
e5 then this is the right move but
here's the reason why
is after black takes back because if you
don't take back well you're just losing
the knight right it can't move it's
pinned so you have to take
queen takes queen
and now this has become an absolute pin
now knight to d5 and importantly
if knight to d7 which was played in the
game this actually doesn't work
because of another really good move
yep work to d1 or castles both work
and the problem is now we have two pins
about to be set up we have one pin here
and one pin here as soon as this knight
moves
there's nothing you can do
in the game
king to e8 was sadly played allowing
knight takes here
and the reason that was played is that's
actually i think the best move if you
play something like h6 right to try and
attack the bishop
then bishop takes
uh bishop takes
knight takes and the knight's pinned
and i've just won this piece right
you have a knight in a bishop and i have
two knights and a bishop
um what else is there if you play c6 to
attack my knight i'll just switch i'll
take here
and again if you take now i'm taking and
forking the king and the rook
uh if you play something like h6 to be
tricky now
i can play knight takes d7 check
take
and knight to b6 check and i'm winning
the rook anyway
this is a brutal position
and all of it came from
e5
if i'll show you on the computer if you
can see plus point four
plus seven point two
one move e5 it looks so natural
um but because it is creating this pin
um we're allowing light to trade in the
center force the king into the corner
and there's just too much pressure
you can't deal with all of the pins
uh yeah so the pierce defense starts
here with um
e4 d6 usually and we'll kind of rotate
around this idea
of black setting up the knight the
bishop this pawn in this format but it
starts with this one d6 move
just really quickly i'll show you how
the game continued the game ended in
like 16 moves but
after after king to e8 allowing the fork
king goes back
knight takes rook h6 attacking the
bishop bishop to e3
b6
f3
bishop attacks the knight and you can't
save it so knight takes pawn
bishop takes and you can't even take the
bishop back because it's still pinned
so the king goes to e7
bishop back to e3 and in this position
black resigned against defeat a master
down a piece or a rook or an exchange uh
it's just this is enough
um okay so now we have some good
introduction to pins and the three
principles right one
pins petrify pieces right the pinch
pieces are petrified they can't move the
second one uh pinned pieces don't
protect right so not only can they not
move that means that they don't have the
influence they did before and three we
want to put pressure on them because
they can't move they can't get away
pressuring the pin pieces adding
attackers is really going to help us out
so we're going to jump into some
practice examples if you think you know
it
feel free to shout out some suggestions
some of these are going to be easier
than those we're going to start a little
simple so in this position it's white to
move and play the only winning move
totally even material um
a piece for a piece pawn for a pawn king
for a king how should white game the
advantage here only winning move
uh
yeah bishop g4 again pretty simple here
um but the idea is the king is too far
away to defend because the knight can't
move there's just nothing to be done and
up a bishop we're going to be able to
win this pawn in guidar's home
a similar idea here black to move play
the only winning move
yeah again this is just to get a flow of
it going right the king is too far away
and
the knight can't move so we're going to
win this piece
and be able to do a nice king and rook
checkmate which if you don't know maybe
another time i'll show you how to do
that
okay uh third example
technically uh it's not the only move to
win here right a queen and a king can
beat a king in a rook but it's one of
the harder like peace versus peace
checkmates if we look at the computer
it's going to tell us it'll take like 30
moves of precise play so instead of
doing that let's find a pin tactic
anybody have an idea
yep queen a7 super simple there's lots
of other ways to do it you could try and
get like a fork
somewhere going but yeah queen x7 is
just immediately shutting down any of
white's hopes then we're going to win
with the queen and king
right to move again play the only
drawing move so in this case a pin isn't
always like a tactic doesn't always mean
we win in this case if we look at it
right it's a rook and a bishop versus a
working knight but black just has an
extra piece
so we're down a piece here but because
of the pin we can win
and a lot of people are throwing it out
in the chat our move here bishop to g6
pinning the knight there's no way to
defend it and we're gonna win it
black to move and play the only winning
move in this position
um
so yeah oh sorry
i was thinking uh bishop to f6 okay uh
did you have a different idea well his
name
same yeah bishop f6 and this is the only
move that does it um
and it's funny in this position white
would love to sacrifice their own pawn
so that rook could come defend
uh but unfortunately that is not a
current rule in chess
so
uh there's no way to to survive this
you're either losing the knight for free
or you're losing the rook um that's
about as simple as it gets
next example here white to move and
again play the only winning move
abc
good another quick one right we have a
rook and a bishop we're lining them up
and the queen and king we hit them
together so these aren't again the most
complicated ideas but i want to build
this habit in of seeing if pieces are
lined up we have a piece that can attack
on multiple angles
a pin can just immediately take a
position that's lost into one that wins
so being able to see these is super
super helpful
all right light to move in this position
rook d1 yes rook d1 okay um let's say i
play
king f 8.
now you're pinned
yes you are pinned but
we can defend the rook
so that's one maybe thing to be aware of
with a pin
is if we're okay with a trade if our
pinned piece can move and defend then
you know so pins aren't perfect we'll
talk about that at the end but
uh again i love the alliteration
oh so in this position if we played f5
here
uh i will just take it oh because it's
still pinned right you can't take me
back i will take your rook
yes so good question
but again it looks like that would
normally be a great move but pin pieces
don't protect it's a shame
uh skipped an example okay
right to move and again play the only
winning move
and i will point out something very
important in this position if we move
our queen somewhere too dramatic this
bishop and queen will checkmate us on g2
so we got to be a little careful
also our queen is not defended so be
aware of both of those facts
it's actually the same as again a few
examples ago i forget which one here
um
yeah this same idea right
it's come back
it's the same pin and amazingly right
it's not this piece wants to take our
queen but it can't it's not it's not
defended so it doesn't matter that we
haven't defended our piece we've removed
the attacker
pinned pieces are petrified yes
this is a really fun one this is
probably the hardest one we've looked at
so far
like to move and play the best move this
is a little more complicated
one of my favorite pin examples though
queen to d5 okay uh what's your idea
that's the key so a move like so some
people in this position will suggest
queen to like a4 or b5 pinning the
knight to the queen and this looks good
but the problem is after rook to uh c6
i've defended it
with queen to d5
now we have two threats the bishop and
the knight
and if you move the rook to defend one i
take the other one
brutal
so because we are pinning both of these
pieces
uh black doesn't have time to answer
both threats
questions on this one
it's a little more complicated but it's
a really cool one uh
um so the only i'm not sure in this
particular example so let's say i go
here
probably this one it's okay to
take with the supporting piece
i get a little hesitant just because i
don't want some kind of weird discovery
to happen so like again this is gonna be
fine but i'm just always going to be a
little hesitant to let my queen hang
um in that particular one it doesn't
matter i can just take but i'm always a
little cautious so
i don't want to get counter pinned so as
long as you're aware of that it
shouldn't really matter
okay
wait to move and again play the only
winning move
yeah simple and sweet rook f8 this
knight now can't move anywhere and uh
this rook is going to be stuck
and actually i think we might just be
able to like straight up win one of
these pieces our threat is immediately
just bishop to f4
and i don't think there's a great way to
stop it
black to move and play the only winning
move
and a little more complicated here
yes
so funny enough in this position uh some
people might not see it immediately but
this bishop is actually not defended
right
it's not obvious to see but uh pin
pieces remember don't protect so we want
to be aware of the pins that are
existing in the position not just the
ones that we create and yeah this is
very unfortunate for our white player
here
all right last practice example and then
i'm going to show you a few other ideas
so wait to move play the only winning
move
queen b2
hitting the rook and there's really
nothing you can do here um you can try
the tricky move
rook to c2 check but
we just take it
so we don't win the queen but we do
still want to work regardless and if
let's say
a non-move let's say black just
passes what would you do here
uh it would be uh rook to c1 yeah we
gotta pile on the pinned piece right
we're putting pressure on it um and now
there's yeah really nothing same thing
you can try to be tricky but it actually
doesn't matter which way we take this
because if we take with the rook we
defend the queen
and if we take the with the queen we get
out of harm's way
so either way is fine
and there's just nothing else black can
do to defend this piece
okay questions about the basics of
pinning or anything we've gone over so
far before we move into a game
everybody feel good
excellent
so this is a really fun game uh paul
morphy was a player in the 1800s one of
the best of the time
and
he is probably most famous for playing
morphy's opera house game a lot of
people have seen that game it's a great
game it uses pins but i want to be i
don't want to be so basic but i'm just
going to show that game so this is
another morphe game
um where he really i think it's just 12
moves long yeah 12 moves
and he wins with some incredible pinning
maneuvers and i want to show it to you
so this was played in 1857 in new york
versus
alexander meek with the black pieces
murphy had white he started with e4
e6 d4
and c5 so this is a little more unusual
usually with the e6 you'll see like a
french defense
with d5 c5 is a playable move and now
we've transposed into a kind of sicilian
defense the main idea here is black
would actually love for white to capture
so they can take back with the bishop
and develop their piece maybe play like
queen to b6 and get an attack on f2
so that's kind of what black is going
for here but there's actually a bit of a
problem and morphe exploits it
d5
taking some space putting some pressure
and now we're actually saying this pawn
is going to be a little weak and a
little backwards
e5 another kind of unusual move just
kind of black accepting their fate with
this pawn but trying to really solidify
on the d4 square gain some control in
the center
still a little offbeat but it's not
losing
and f4
uh interesting move by morphe earlier i
said i didn't love f4 because it exposes
us to queenside attacks
here it's maybe okay because you know
g43 is going to defend and it's going to
be a little weird but
i still don't think getting the queen
out this early is a huge problem
and now it's actually kind of the same
as we saw before now white would love
for black to take this piece because we
can then develop our bishop
d6 defending
knight to f3 putting pressure in the
center and bishop to g4 so meek creates
a pin
pawn takes pawn
bishop takes knight so this is a little
in between move we now don't have time
to complete the capture we got to save
our queen so queen takes
and pawn takes back everything is still
even
bishop to b5 check this is a really nice
move
um getting our last piece in the game
and also doing it in a way normally this
move is not as good because they're
going to have a bishop they're happy to
trade
or because
a pawn can just push but with c5 played
and the bishop traded away
this is a great move we're forcing the
knight to pin itself
and in the game yeah knight to d7 was
played
we also have the option now of castling
and putting a lot of pressure on f7
that is not what murphy decided to go
for i believe
he played knight to c3 just a simple
development move
which is also fine
knight to f6 and now
bishop to g5 and we have a beautiful
double pin setup
and
there's a very similar idea if you've
seen the opera house
where both of these knights are on these
exact same squares
pinned by these two bishops
and something really funny about this is
because both knights are pinned it looks
like they should be defending each other
but they're actually not
really all these knights are doing is
just taking up space and cramping
black's position
because without these knights black
might be able to move the queen
somewhere a little more valuable but
it's actually just
keeping it too congested
so this is a really strong move
uh in this position
meek plays bishop to e7
and i believe we are at move
10 so white plays two more moves and
then black resigns
um
if anyone would like to hazard a guess
at what white should do here
feel free to uh throw out some ideas how
should white get
yes push that okay so if i play d6
that's not defended so i'm probably just
going to take it
uh king cider queenside
yeah queen side um i honestly i like
them both both rooks are going to be
relevant right
if we have a rook here with the queen
lined up against the king that's going
to be nice but also having this pawn
that might support your pawn push idea
uh
yes both are half open files um rooks
love open files
so yeah both of those would be great
queen f5 being suggested
so queen fire looks nice we are putting
more pressure on this knight
although i think with queen f5 um
i think maybe just castles
and now we've broken out of the pin so
this knight is now both knights are
defending each other right so now we
can't really try and win either night
because then the other night can come in
so queen five looks good but i don't
think it's quite fast enough
both castles are good moves
they're just not crushing
i think they will still get the job done
but there's a really crushing move
um
bishop takes de7
okay bishop takes d7 again this is a
nice idea but
unfortunately because of bishop e7 the
knights now are defending each other
so it's still good like black's still
gonna survive this we can do a big trade
we could castle and put pressure on f7
but
i think block's gonna be okay
it's not an obvious looking move until
you see why it's so good
um
i'll give you another minute or so and
then i will help you out
so joe bruno stl also suggesting d6 so
we looked at this
and the problem seems to be that it's
not defended the bishop is going to take
uh this one here
so if we oh sorry wait bishop e7 so
if we take um
this knight can't move but now the
bishop is here to take back
do you have a follow-up here
um i was thinking
yeah if pawn takes that would be a
little nicer um i think black still may
be a little fortified but the king is
like a little more exposed with this
weakness but if bishop takes yeah it's
even better so
any last guesses are going to help you
out if you played g6 yeah
if you could
uh
clear out the player with a knight to go
to d5
okay so you're thinking of sacking the
pawn bishop takes
knight to d5 okay so now we're getting
somewhere interesting we're noticing
that uh d6
isn't just giving up a pawn it is
actually moving this
yeah this bishop boy yeah joe bruno
question what you said yeah so whoever
said i reset d6 and here's what's
actually amazing so d6 is the right move
knight to d5
i think will probably be good enough
um
this looks great morphe played an even
slightly better move he just queenside
castled
and now
the bishop is undefended
if the bishop moves the knight is hit by
the bishop and the rook so it's double
pinned this knight is still pinned
so what do you do if you just play
bishop e7
then i'm going to take your knight
and then i'm going to take this knight
and you probably don't want to give me
your queen
so you can move
and now i have a beautiful discovered
attack
defending my bishop hitting your king
and i'm going to play bishop to c4 and
i'm going to threaten this pawn and your
position has just completely crumbled
i'm up a piece i'm very happy
so you can't just play bishop e7 if you
try for some kind of counter attack like
h6 this also doesn't work
uh can't help me out with why this
doesn't work
were you just trading bishops right
uh we could trade bishops yeah
so
this is essentially saying rook takes
and then pawn takes
when
yeah so bishop takes and uh
i can't move this knight so i have to
take
i guess i could take with a queen here
and yeah regardless of how all the
trading ends this bishop is still
hanging
so i have uh two pieces for your one and
i'm also just putting a ton of pressure
on it
so yeah really good
um so yeah just taking is simple enough
you can also take this knight is going
to be fine as well
because after the queen takes we're
going to do a similar thing here
and we're going to fork the bishop in
the rook
so amazingly white is just winning in
every variation it's a beautiful
position to be in when you can't play a
losing move
um
but all of this comes from just this
these beautiful pins right it's such a
simple position
and sure in this position i'm going to
say
even yeah in this position white's
better
but i don't think it's crushing
but just some really simple moves bishop
to b5
bishop to g5 and these knights now are
just so helpless
uh and it just undermines everything in
the position and there's no time bishop
e7 is too slow h6 in this position is
also too slow um
because here we can take
and you can't take with this knight so
we're intentionally removing this
defender
and we're going to do a similar thing
we're going to instead of winning a
bishop we're hitting a pawn in the rook
um when they move
the pin that's when we capitalize and we
have to trade our bishop right
yeah so the reason we're doing this
first is because
we don't want the queen to be able to
take back here we want to damage the
pawn structure
so that when our queen takes we're
hitting the rook in the pawn and again
everything's falling so you're going to
save the rook i don't actually know
what's better here but
we're going to get checked and this is
still going to be plenty good enough for
white to win we have two beautiful
center pawns
um we're going to be able to castle
either way and our rooks are going to be
really good either way so
um yeah there was just really nothing
that could be done in this position it's
just already too lost
because you didn't deal with either of
these pins
so really fun game again 12 moves morph
versus meek great game to look at for
just examples of pins
um we got a little bit more time i want
to do a little bit of a cautionary tale
as i mentioned a little before pins
aren't perfect so i want to give a few
quick examples and things to watch out
for when you're looking for pins in your
games
so let's just look at a possible opening
here again e4
c5 sicilian
d4
and c3 and this is a smith moore gambit
if anyone's seen this or maybe anyone
plays this it's kind of a hyper
aggressive way for white you're giving
up two pawns
but you're getting some rapid activity
right a knight and a pawn come out and
this is
maybe slightly better for black with
good play but white gets a lot of
advantages a lot of development so
nothing wrong at a early level playing
like this
so like knight to c6 we're just going to
play some normal moves
you know getting our pieces in the
center
and black here plays bishop to g4
pinning our knight to the queen and this
is actually a mistake this looks like a
really solid normal move developing our
piece
maybe we want a queen side castle though
it's probably unlikely but you know
we're just creating a pin
what's the problem here
what should white respond with
[Music]
oh we could um
yeah bishop b5 that would be an option
although i don't know that that's going
to be kind of a crushing win for us like
black's at very worst black can just
retreat and then we both moved our
bishop twice and black's in a fine
position
yeah there are a few people who i think
have it in the chat
there's kind of two ideas um
but both of them revolve around the fact
that this bishop is not defended
and uh
a poor pin
is really just a discovery waiting to
happen
bishop takes f7
and after the king takes
check
we're winning our bishop back
and your king can't move so because this
piece wasn't defended it looks like this
is a great pin but really it was an
opportunity for us to move our knight
and win a piece so you have to be a
little bit careful of that um someone
else in the chat suggested knight e5
which is kind of brutal with the idea
that oh you can take my queen and then i
can get checkmate
that's pretty funny i don't know if that
100 works because i think knight takes
e5 defends the bishop and that's going
to cause a little bit of problems but
it's a cute idea
um maybe knight g5 a little better
well i still don't want to give it my
queen probably i just need to take
so uh yeah the idea is we've drawn the
king away and we're going to get a
discovery so you always want to be a
little careful that whatever piece
you're pinning really can't move right
because in this case i don't want to
lose my queen but it's a relative pin
i definitely don't want black to lose
the king
is queen b3 also
yeah that's a really good point queen v3
is also a good move in this position
um this is actually a fork right so
we're one uh preparing to take on f7 but
we're also hitting this b7 pawn this is
i think the second best move in the
position it's still a good advantage for
white
so that's a good one to be aware of too
but yeah either of those are going to be
winning ideas
all right next example this is one that
comes out of a really common opening the
philidor defense
e4 e5 knight to f3 and d6 uh the idea
here is we're not committing our knight
to c6 yet for black and we're actually
opening up space for our bishop to come
out so bishop to g4 is a common idea in
this philidor
it's maybe a little bit passive right
we're not putting a lot of pressure on
the center like a normal knight to c6
would but not a bad move
um d4
and bishop to g4 this is
common theory um
and after d takes e5 black actually has
to be a little bit careful
um
because
if pawn takes the pawn back
black is actually
in trouble
if pawn takes pawn what's the problem
yeah we've removed the piece that was
pinned right or sorry we removed the
target of the pin so the knight now is
just happy to take this pawn we just
went upon for free so there's something
else you have to be careful of this idea
is called an inner meso which is i think
an italian word um but it just means
it's an in-between type of move so
normally we wouldn't be able to
recapture this but because we have this
in-between move where we're forcing you
to respond in a very certain way we get
rid of the piece that is causing this
pin and now our knight is free to move
so for any philidor defense players the
correct move in this position is to take
the knight
after the queen takes
you win the pawn back and it's all even
so again something to be a little aware
of there as well
a few others
somebody's asking can we show us if king
d7 but i'm not sure exactly what
variation you're talking about so if you
say that if you say what variation you
want me to look at
i will help you out
uh here's another fun one um also kind
of hard to see but this is called the
elephant trap and it's another thing
that i really like to play
d4 and this is for black d5 c4 we have a
queen's gambit really common
idea if you're not familiar is
if black takes this pawn and accepts the
gambit white is almost always going to
win it back by moving their e pawn and
then the bishop will take it back and
it's usually not worth the hassle for
black to try and hang on to that pawn so
it's just a trade
um
okay we'll take a look at that mhm as
soon as we finish this one so e6
knight two c3
knight to f6
and bishop to g5 again we have a pin
here relative pin
and in this position there's lots of
ways for
black to respond right the idea is
they're putting pressure on our knight
and putting pressure on the center
some people will play bishop to e7 here
unpinning some people will play c6 here
defending
there's lots of moves you can play one
move that you don't see all the time but
it's kind of a tricky move is this
knight to d7
and this looks like a blunder
it looks like a blender because after
pawn takes pawn
pawn takes pawn now the knight can take
because our knights pinned and this
knight is not only not helped this night
but it's also blocked our queen from
defending so this just looks like a
horrible move that a new player would
just play without thinking
the problem is
this is exactly what black wants
it's black to move in this position and
find a killer move
sorry
yeah knight takes d5
giving up the queen
and now
absolutely brutal
the king is almost mated and there's
only one way to not get mated to give
the queen right back
and when all the dust settles the only
thing that happened
that was not an evil equal exchange is
we got to take a knight for a pawn
we have three pieces and they have two
and they have one extra pawn so it's a
really funny trap um
and again you can see exactly what
happens is this knight takes this pawn
and we take that knight everything else
is dead even
um so again you got to be a little
careful some people are kind of crafty
and know that beginners like pins pins
are still always great and i love
recommending them but you do have to be
aware there are some ways to exploit
them
uh yeah this is a fun trap in the uh
the queen's gambit declined called the
elephant uh trap
okay so real quick i want to go back and
see
help our friend here with what this
puzzle was
uh puzzles when i played bishop takes f7
so that was here
uh so here in our
smith mora i did bishop takes f7
and you were suggesting something else
bishop f7 king d7
oh
oh i see yeah so you're saying if bishop
f7 king d7
um i mean that's fine you can play king
d7
i'm just gonna move my bishop back
and
yeah my piece is still pinned but i want
a pawn for nothing and your king is now
on d7 so i'm happy with this
um
there in some strange worlds there's
maybe a variation where eventually i
play knight to e5 because this pawn is
pinned now and i fork i can't do that
because this knight right now but you
know maybe there's a world where that
happens but yeah kg7 not a big problem
okay a couple more i want to show you
two more examples of cautionary tales
against pins i still really advocate
them they're super super great but
you've got to be aware and then we'll
look at three final kind of practice
examples that are a little more advanced
so this is a common one called
legalesmate
there's lots of ways to reach this
position um
but here's the most common
we create the pin
h3 to push the bishop back and now white
to move and if you've seen it you
already know how brutal it is wait to
even play absolutely crushing move
yeah again knight takes e5 it's the same
idea we're sacking and now the idea is
if bishop takes queen how do we win
king has one square
checkmate
absolutely gross
just brutal um this king has no moves
every square is covered
so
okay but there's two other options right
we don't have to take the queen
what if
um
if they just do something like the
bishop back well we just want a pawn so
we're doing fine we can take the bishop
and weaken the pawns more we can take
the knight and make double pawns here we
got lots of options but we're fine just
winning a pawn if you try and hold on to
everything
if you take the knight for instance
let's say you take it with the pawn
well now like we just saw any bad pin is
just a discovery so i just take the
bishop and again i won a pawn and i
traded a night for a bishop
and if i take with the knight i'll do
the same thing here and you might say
wait a minute but your bishop's free too
how would white respond here
uh queen b5
forking the king and the knight
so we're going to win it back either way
again um and we just went upon in these
variations but it's a center pawn so
it's a crucial one
and we did it with
kind of a pretty stylish move
right knight takes e5 and most people
are just going to think you're a dummy
and take your queen so this probably
won't happen but it's still good to know
you know that white's ahead no matter
what they play
one final
uh this is called league gals mate um or
we got strap if they don't take the bait
and get checkmated but it's a good one
to know this pattern of
knights bishop and this knight's going
to come in and all the squares are going
to be covered
so it's a valuable one to know
one final game here
this is a super super fun game it's
called the skewer lure
and we have e4 e5 knight to f3 knight to
c6 we have an italian game
and uh d4
so a little aggressive in the center and
we saw a similar idea with the scotch
gan but we were looking at earlier where
we sack a pawn in this case they don't
take if you recall
how they taken here then white is happy
after rook to e1
d5
and we get this really nice
double pin we're winning the piece back
so
uh it's just some familiarity with the
position but in this case uh they
decided not to take the pawn and play
bishop to e7
knight takes d4
regaining that pawn and then knight
takes queen takes
d6
f4 uh maybe preparing e5
b6 looking to give a bishop a home maybe
here put some pressure on the king
and e5 like we said f4 helping uh to
support the center
pawn is pushed and now there's a bit of
a threat that we need to be careful of
so what would happen if i just played my
bishop back to like e2 say what would
black play
i'll just do it
dude
they might or
they might play bishop c5
pinning our queen to the king
so we have to be a little aware of
what's going on in the position right
we're threatening a knight and they're
threatening a queen
so in the game the move played was uh
bishop to b5 check right saving our
bishop and stalling with the move and
there's no way to play c6 here because
it's not defended
so bishop to d7
and white plays pawn takes the knight
and what did we just see
yeah bishop c5 pinning
but what if i told you
that white actually saw this variation
and decided to keep calculating
white actually has a really killer idea
check
okay well
here i can't move the bishop because
it's pinned
if i move this bishop then i've lost my
thread on your queen and i'm just going
to take it for free
and if i move the queen then the same
thing i'm just going to lose a queen
so what's the point of me doing this
certainly only move
into f8
spawn forking the king in the rook
with the rook cutting us off we have one
move
checkmate
with a pinned queen
uh now pinned pieces do not protect this
is a rule that applies in every
circumstance except when a king is
attacking because a king
can never move into check the way i
would think about it it's a little
confusing sometimes is think about you
would say wait but this queen can't move
because then i would take your king but
which king dies first
you take the queen i take your king
first and then you take mine so
whoever's king goes first that you can't
do it doesn't work
so really fun game here we got
just like two three minutes left so i
want to show you three more examples
these are a little more advanced but
let's see what you can do
white to move and play the only winning
move
so rook takes f5 uh your queen is not
defended i will take it
uh your queen is still not defended
but the background
brutal
this is checkmate and even worse
you can't take the rook because i'm
pinning you
so it's a double pin
you can't move your queen off here i
take the rook and you can't move your
queen down here or i take the king
really brutal in this case
i don't even think there's a good move
you're just losing your queen
that's rough
light to move and in this position
we are down we have two rooks versus two
rooks
uh
three night or sorry two knights and a
bishop versus one night in bishops we're
down a piece but it is white to move and
play the only move that draws
chesteroid you have the right idea the c
pawn marches forward c4
this night now has to move
and our rook is going to pin their
bishop to the king so after the night
goes anywhere
the march is on
you cannot take my pawn because you are
pinned
really we're winning the piece back
and yes it draws amazingly
last example
like to move and again play the only
move that draws if you were in a game
and you are losing don't give up you can
still draw if you find the right tactic
bishop takes e5
okay bishop takes e5
yes so i can't take back with the pawn
or else i lose my queen so i will take
back with the queen
okay now i take back with the pawn
okay i take back with the pump
good
good
the rook is still
there
and we win our piece back
you have to do that in a very precise
order right any other move doesn't work
because if we take the bishop first then
you can just take with the queen
and if you take um
i don't know if you do something like
this it still doesn't work i can still
just take with the queen you have to be
very precise with that so really really
good
well that was all the time we have
tonight but thank you all for joining me
both in person and on the stream it's
been a pleasure my name is alex muller
and i hope to see you again next